[Music]
Why hello there. You've caught me on the
20th floor. I feel like we're high
enough that I can sit down for this one,
which of course we are talking about my
RTX 5060 review. They tried to ensure
this didn't happen and we went to great
lengths to make sure that it would. So,
here we are. We have a GeForce RTX 5060.
We even have a driver because, you know,
we waited till it was publicly available
and then didn't sleep and provided this
review. But before we do, our Computex
coverage is brought to you by MSI's
excellent QDLE gaming monitors, offering
perfect blacks, infinite contrast, and
lightning fast response times. MSI QD
OLED monitors are the best way to level
up your gaming experience. And there are
options for everyone. Whether you're
after an incredible 4K panel or a
blistering 500 Hz refresh rate, all with
the latest features like true HDR, a
custom graphine film to cool the
display, and HDMI 2.1 with full console
support. Check the links below to learn
more about MSI's
QDLESs. Also supporting our Computex
trip this year is Thermal Grizzly and
their Juronaut higherformance thermal
paste, offering extreme long-term
stability combined with outstanding
thermal conductivity. It's not
electrically conductive and won't harden
over time. So, for more information,
please check the links in the video
description. So, real quick, the RTX
5060 is based on the same GB 206 silicon
as the 5060Ti series, meaning the 181 mm
die packs 21.9 billion transistors.
Though, of course, not all of them will
be in use for this particular part as
the core count has been reduced by 17%.
though that still sees the 5060 packing
25% more cores than the older 4060. Not
only that, but through the use of 28
Gbits pers GDDR7 memory, bandwidth has
increased by 65% to 448 GB
pers. But unfortunately, this model is
limited to just 8 GB of VRAM, which is
bad. though, at least in this particular
example, there is just a single
configuration. So, in my opinion, it's
far less of a trap for gamers when
compared to the more expensive 8 GB
version of the
5060Ti. But unfortunately, making the
obvious VRAM limitation even worse is
the PCIe
5.0* 8 bus interface, which is less than
ideal for those of you with a PCIe 5.0 0
enabled system and a complete disaster
for those of you using older hardware,
particularly when limited to PCIe 3.0.
And that is something that I'll have to
explore when I return home from Taiwan.
Now, for testing, I have an AM5 test
system in my hotel room. A very similar
system to what I normally use. It does
feature a Ryzen 7 9800 X3D processor
which I brought with me along with my
GSkill Trident Z5 DDR5 6000 CL30 memory
kit and of course my test system SSD. So
a big thank you to MSI for helping to
provide everything else required to make
this content possible. It has been an
interesting and challenging process to
make this review over here in Taiwan,
but I think all the effort's been worth
it. So let's get into the data. The
first game we have here is Clare Obscure
Expedition 33. And here the RTX 5060
averaged just 48 FPS at 1080p, which is
the same kind of performance you can
expect from the much older 3060 Ti,
making it just 17% faster than the RTX
4060. Increasing the resolution when
using the Epic preset isn't really an
option, as the RTX 5060 is not powerful
enough, and with just 8 GB of VRAM, it
runs out of video memory. Anyway, the
5060Ti 16 GB, for example, is usable
here, while the 8 GB model is completely
broken. Next, we have Oblivion
Remastered. And here we're looking at 45
FPS on average at 1080p, which is
roughly equivalent to the 4060 Ti and
RTX 3070. So, 25% faster than the RTX
4060. And then at 1440p, we again run
into VRAMm issues. 34 FPS is technically
playable. At least that's what some of
you tell me. But with 1% lows of just 18
FPS, the gameplay was very choppy and
therefore I deem
unplayable. Moving on to Delta Force.
Performance here looks much better. 138
FPS at 1080p, though that is again just
RTX 3060Ti like performance coming in
slower than the RTX
4060Ti. It's much the same story at
1440p with the RTX 5060 sitting between
the 3060 Ti and 3070. Though this time
performance is closer to the
3070. Stalker 2 sees the RTX 5060 render
47 FPS on average at 1080p which is once
again similar performance to that of the
RTX 3060 Ti and just a 9% improvement
over the RTX 4060. Then at 1440p we're
once again crippled by the 8 GB VRAM
buffer reducing the RTX 5060 to 6 FPS on
average. So not super usable I'd say.
Now, the RTX 5060 does make for an
excellent esports GPU, delivering strong
performance in Counterstrike 2 at 1080p
using the medium preset. Surprisingly,
that is a 27% increase over the RTX
4060, though it is again similar
performance that of the old RTX 3070.
It's a similar story at 1440p. Here, the
RTX 5060 was able to render 370 FPS on
average, making it slightly faster than
the Radeon RX 7700
XT. Space Marine 2 played very well at
1080p. 100 FPS on average provided an
excellent experience and a 23%
improvement over the RTX 4060. Then at
1440p, we're looking at a massive 33%
increase over the 4060 for what is very
much 7700 XT light
performance. Star Wars Jedi Survivor
also ran quite well with 95 fps on
average at 1080p, which in this example
resulted in 4060 Ti and 3070 light
performance. We're looking at similar
performance trends at 1440p. again 4060
Ti and 3070 light performance this time
with 57 FPS on average. So 30% faster
than the RTX 4060 which is impressive to
see. Call of Duty Black Ops 6 saw the
RTX 5060 render 75 fps at 1080p which
was a mere 10% uplift from the 4060 and
7% slower than the RTX 3070. So not a
great result here and it's a similar
story at 1440p. Basically, we're looking
at RTX 3060 Ti levels of performance.
So, really highly disappointing after
all this
time. Here, we're seeing just a 5%
improvement over the RTX 3070 in a
playtail recreum at 1080p, making the
RTX 5060 slightly slower than the 7700
XT, though it was a massive 36% faster
than the RTX 4060.
It also crushed the 4060 at 1440p this
time offering 33% better performance,
though it did only match the RTX 3070
and
4060Ti. The Starfield performance was
even weaker. At 1080p, the 5060 only
matched the RTX 3060Ti with 55 fps. Then
at 1440p, we're looking at similar
margins, just 5% faster than the RTX
3060Ti with 44 FPS on
average. Performance in Cyberpunk 2077
at 1080p is quite good. 100 FPS on
average meant that the RTX 5060 was able
to match the
4060Ti, making it 28% faster than the
regular RTX 4060. Then at 1440p, it
managed 66 fps. Again, delivering 4060
Ti and RTX 3070 light performance,
making it 35% faster than the RTX 4060
in this particular example. The God of
War Ragnarok performance at 1080p was
surprisingly strong from the RTX 5060,
beating the 4060 by a massive 45% margin
with 128 FPS.
That margin was heavily reduced at
1440p, but even so, it was still 32%
faster than the 4060. Again, delivering
RTX 3070 and 4060 Ti like performance.
You'll be shocked to learn that the RTX
5060 is an RTX 3070 and Dying Light 2
while also matching the 4060Ti. And of
course, we are seeing a similar thing at
1440p. Though, here the Ark B 580 is
also added to the mix for something a
little bit different.
Interestingly, Dragon Age: The Valgard
was a struggle. Here we're rendering
just 68 FPS at 1080p, making the 5060 a
mere 11% faster than the 4060 and quite
a bit slower than the RTX 3070 and 4060
Ti. The margins are reduced at 1440p.
And now the 5060 is similar to the RTX
3070 and 4060 Ti, though with just 49
FPS on average. The performance wasn't
exactly
amazing. Spider-Man remastered wasn't an
issue for the RTX 5060 at
1080p. 159 FPS on average allowed it to
edge out the 4060 Ti and RTX 3070,
resulting in a 25% performance uplift
over the RTX 4060. The 1440p results are
very typical. Yes, frame rates were good
with 110 FPS, but relative to the other
models, performance was what you'd
expect, matching the ARK B580, 4060Ti,
and RTX
3070. The 1080p performance in Hogwarts
Legacy was also very good. 101 FPS,
which meant the 5060 was slightly faster
than the 3070 and much faster than the
4060 Ti. and then way faster than the
4060, 44% faster. In fact, this game is
very memory demanding, so maybe the
GDDR7 memory is utilized well. Having
said that though, we appear to run into
some other bottleneck at 1440p, as here
the 5060 is once again only able to
match the 4060 Ti and as a result wound
up 13% faster than the 4060. The Last of
Us Part One placed the 5060 alongside
the 4060 Ti at 1080p with 85 FPS on
average, making it 25% faster than the
RTX 4060. However, jumping up to 1440p
breaks the RTX 5060 as 8 GB isn't enough
VRAM to deliver consistent frame time
performance in this title using the
ultra quality settings. Finally, we have
Star Wars Outlaws. And at 1080p, the RTX
5060 is very poor, rendering just 42
FPS, which is a mere 8% uplift over the
4060. Then at 1440p, we're down to just
31 FPS on average. Though this did make
it 19% faster than the RTX 4060, but
overall pretty weak performance.
Okay, so across the 18 games tested, the
RTX 5060 matched the RTX 4060Ti and RTX
3070, coming in 6% slower than the
Radeon RX 7700 XT. It was also 22%
faster than the RTX 4060, which is
roughly what Nvidia claimed. Now,
jumping up to 1440p, we did see examples
where the 8 GB GPUs were broken. And in
some examples, performance does appear
to be fine, but the visual presentation
takes a hit as textures that don't fit
into the local video memory simply go
missing, resulting in a muddy
presentation. Overall though, the 5060
was again on par with the 3070 and 4060
Ti series. All of these GPUs do feature
8 GB of VRAM, and then it was 6% faster
than Intel's Arc B580 and 27% faster
than the 4060.
Now, as you might imagine, any kind of
truly transformative ray tracing
experience is going to be very
difficult, if not impossible, to achieve
with an RTX 5060 simply because the GPU
itself is not that powerful, along with
the fact that it does only have 8 GB of
VRAM, which isn't nearly enough for RA
tracing in modern games. For example,
we're looking at just 36 fps on average
in Allen Wakeake 2 at 1080p, though this
is with DLSS quality upscaling, which
isn't really 1080p. And that meant the
RTX 5060 was 20% faster than the 4060,
but 14% slower than the 4060 Ti. Then,
for those of you hoping to game at
1440p, well, RA tracing on an RTX 5060
is simply not going to be an option for
that. Now, with the help of upscaling in
Cyberpunk 2077, it is possible to get
near 60 fps at 1080p using the ultra RT
preset. Though again, as I just said
earlier, this is not really 1080p
because we are talking about upscaling,
but you guys get it. And that is similar
performance to the ARB 580, so not
great. Again, 1440p is out of the
question, and we did run into some VRAM
limitations in our short test. Now,
Marvel's Spider-Man Remastered is a well
optimized title, and even with RA
tracing maxed out, we're looking at 112
FPS on average with the RTX 5060, which
is similar performance to the 4060 Ti.
Then at 1440p, it does pull well clear
of the 4060 Ti with 109 FPS on average.
So, a pretty good result here, almost
matching the RTX 4070, something we've
not really seen that much of. And
typically, you would expect a product
named the 5060 to at least match the
previous generation part positioned a
tier higher. Dying Light 2 at upscaled
1080p with the high ray tracing preset
saw the RTX 5060 render 72fps. The same
level of performance seen from the 7700
XT and 4060Ti.
So usable, but not amazing. Despite
being almost 30% faster than the RTX
4060, it's a bit of a struggle at 1440p,
rendering 48 FPS on average, which was
comparable performance to the 7700 XT
and RTX 4060 Ti. Now, look, I know I
know the MSRP for the most part isn't
real, but I just wanted to take a look
at how things should stack up. And then
of course we will look at real retail
pricing. So if all GPUs were sold at the
suggested price, the ARC B580 would be
the best value choice, followed by the
RX970 and then the RTX 5060, which works
out to come in at a cost per frame at
$5.35. That's a 21% improvement from the
RTX 4060 and 30% from the RTX 3060. So
that's pretty good. or it would be if it
had some more VRAM and we'll talk more
about that in a moment. For now, let's
look at the real US
pricing. Okay, so at the time of making
this video, the RTX 5060 is available
for order. So, it is in stock over at
Newegg for $330 US, which is 10% over
the MSRP. However, in the current
market, that does make it rather good
value. Or at least that's how it appears
if you ignore the elephant in the room,
which of course is that 8 GB VRAM
buffer. But ignoring that, even with
some games providing very poor results
due to a lack of VRAM, though in some
examples, this mostly only negatively
affected the frame time performance, the
5060 is 8% better value than the 7800
XT, which isn't amazing given the Radeon
GPU packs 16 GB of VRAM and doesn't
suffer those performance related issues
we just spoke of. when compared to the
outgoing RX7600, it is 14% better value
and at 21% better value than remaining
RTX 4060 stock. So, as the market is
right now, as things stand, the RTX 5060
appears to be decent value for those of
you looking to purchase a brand new
graphics card, but with just 8 GB of
VRAM, it's not a product I can recommend
at that price. And of course, AMD does
have a competitor incoming, and you'll
hear more about that very, very shortly.
So, there you have it. Overall, the RTX
5060 appears to stack up quite well, and
as long as you don't look too closely,
you could conclude that it's a good
value product. However, a deeper
analysis will reveal a troubled product
that is going to almost certainly age
incredibly poorly. As we very clearly
established at this point, 8 GB of VRAM
simply isn't enough. and in 2025
shouldn't be a configuration found on
any product priced over $200 US. As an
esports product, it works well enough.
Though, if that's what you're after, I'd
suggest entertaining the secondhand
market. It's frustrating how good the
RTX 5060 could have been. Even if it was
armed with 12 GB of VRAM at the current
price, I feel as though it would have
been a product I could recommend.
Perhaps I'd do so tentatively, but still
I could entertain the idea of
recommending it and with 16 gigabytes it
could be a pretty solid product. Of
course, we do have those Radeon GPUs
incoming, which is always going to be a
major concern, but still it would be a
usable product with some sort of legs to
carry it into the future in my opinion.
As it stands though, the RTX 5060 is
like an onsale RTX 4060 Ti offering a
25% saving, which sounds nice enough,
but really after almost exactly 2 years
now, who's getting excited for that? And
if you go back further, well, it just
becomes an RTX 3070 with a 40% discount,
though almost 5 years have passed since
the release of the Ampia GPU. So again,
not terribly exciting, certainly not
impressive. And again, Nvidia had a
clear opportunity to offer a worthwhile
upgrade here had the RTX 5060 packed
more VRAM, but as it stands, the end
result means they've been essentially
making the same GPU for 5 years now,
offering a discount every few years. But
as I've noted, the big problem for
Nvidia is going to be the incoming
Radeon RX 9060 XT series. and we'll be
able to share all of those juicy details
shortly. But if what we've been told
becomes reality, then the RTX 5060 is
absolutely not something you should even
consider. It is going to be, or it is,
dead on arrival, or at least it will be
for those of you who pay attention to
real online reviews. And on that note,
Nvidia has handled this release very
poorly. I mean, I can't put into words
what they've done here. It has been a
complete PR disaster. And who would have
guessed that Nvidia's marketing team is
better than AMD at converting GeForce
owners into Radeon owners. Actually, now
that I think about it, that was probably
the only way it was ever going to
happen. Finally, a big thank you to
GSkill and Trikes for helping to make
our Computex trip possible this year.
GSkill offers an amazing range of DDR5
memory with AMD Expo support, allowing
you to get the most out of your Ryzen
processor. and we've been using their
Trident Z5 Neo memory in our test
systems for years now as we rely on it
to get the best results. We've also
started using Trix coolers and I've got
to say the Panorama SE 360 Black is one
of the best looking AIO's I've ever
seen. The quality of the rotatable
display is incredible and as complex as
the design appears, it's remarkably
quick and easy to install. So, for more
information, please check the links in
the video description. Anyway, that's
going to do it for this review of the
RTX 5060. I wanted to call it more of a
preview than a review since we rushed it
a fair bit, but claiming to have an RTX
5060 preview is a pretty big cell phone
right now. So, let's just go with quick
review. I'll cover stuff like RT
performance in more detail when we get
back to Australia and of course include
stuff like power, data, and overclocking
results. It was just a bit too difficult
to cover all of that stuff from my hotel
room in Taiwan. But I've done my
absolute best to get this review done
for you guys. So, if you appreciate it,
please do like the video, subscribe for
more content. Uh, and really that's
about it. So, I'm your host, Steve. I'll
see you again next time.
[Music]